Salut aujourd'hui on est samedi, c'est le jour du masterclass.
Aujourd'hui je vous donne une technique, une vraie technique qui permet de retenir un jeu de cartes dans l'ordre.
Vous allez donc pouvoir retenir 52 cartes dans un ordre complètement aléatoire mélangé par quelqu'un.
Vous allez faire ce truc de ouf.
Ce ne sera pas le masterclass le plus long en fait à vous expliquer,
par contre ça va peut-être être un des plus longs à mettre en place pour vous, à travailler,
c'est assez long à faire mais après c'est un petit peu comme la table de rappel,
c'est au bénéfice de toute une vie
Pour ça on va utiliser le système PAO.
P comme personnage,
A comme action,
et O comme objet.
L'idée est très simple, c'est la plus simple du monde
Il faut attribuer à chacune des 52 cartes d'un jeu, un personnage, une action et un objet.
Un petit peu comme la table de rappel
avec laquelle vous codifiez un nombre ou un chiffre par une image
Là, vous allez coder chaque carte par 3 données
Par le nom d'un personnage donc la visualisation d'un personnage, la visualisation d'une action et la visualisation d'un objet.
Exemple personnel avec l'as de pique.
L'as de pique pour moi en personne c'est Maurice
parce que j'ai un ami qui s'appelle Maurice et qui a un tatouage de l'as de pique sur le bras
En Action
L'action, l'action de l'as de pique pour moi c'est sucer
Bah oui forcément je sais à quoi vous pensez, je suis mentaliste... Comme sucer son doigt ou... peu importe...
C'est terrible ça
Et l'objet c'est la Tour Eiffel
donc pour moi cette carte c'est Maurice qui suce la Tour Eiffel en fait
Une Tour Eiffel miniature, j'en sais rien
Et j'ai ce genre de chose de codé pour les 52 cartes de mon jeu
Si je prend le 7 de carreaux
pour moi le 7 de carreaux c'est James Bond pour le personnage parce que 007
c'est tirer pour l'action, tirer au fusil, au revolver
et l'objet se sont des fenêtres
donc c'est James Bond qui tire au revolver dans des fenêtres
Etc... etc... pour toutes les cartes.
C'est ce qu'il y a de plus long à mettre en place
Mais une fois que vous maitrisez les 3 données pour les 52 cartes
ça permet de retenir le jeu de cartes beaucoup plus vite par groupe de 3
Et pour retenir un groupe de 3, vous allez prendre le personnage pour la 1ère carte,
l'action de la 2ème carte et l'objet de la 3ème carte
Ca va vous faire instantanément une petite scénette comme on avait fait par exemple pour les numéros de téléphone
et ça se retiendra immédiatement.
Si par exemple je retourne le roi de trèfle, pour moi c'est Dali, ça c'est le peintre Dali,
je retourne le 7 de carreaux, vous le savez, c'est tirer, tirer au revolver
et l'as de pique c'est la Tour Eiffel
Là instantanément je vois Dali avec un gros pistolet à pompe, je ne sais pas pourquoi, en train de tirer dans la Tour Eiffel.
Dali c'est le roi de trèfle, tirer c'est le 7 de carreaux, Tour Eiffel c'est l'as de pique
C'est des choses que je ne peux pas oublier car c'est ça que j'ai travaillé au préalable.
Donc au lieu de retenir 52 cartes différentes d'une grosse masse de chose à retenir
Vous allez retenir 17 petites scénettes et 1 ou 2 cartes en plus
Mais vous allez retenir beaucoup moins de choses du coup
C'est tout l'intérêt d'utiliser le système PAO pour ça, c'est d'avoir le sentiment qu'on a moins de choses à apprendre
Et en plus on apprends pas parce qu'encore une fois on crée des souvenirs avec des images
Vous pouvez upgrader la difficulté si jamais vous trouvez ça trop simple
C'est de retenir en fait la position de la carte dans le jeu
Quelle carte est en 17 ? Quelle carte est en 52 ? Quelle carte est en 20ème position ?
Chacun à sa méthode pour ça, moi j'utilise les images de la table de rappel
Que je vous avais expliqué sur l'un des 1er masterclass
Je prends en fond de décor de chaque scénette une de mes images clé de la table de rappel
Donc pour le 1er groupe de 3, personnage, action, objet
je vais mettre comme fond de décor une forêt de sapins
parce que vous vous souvenez peut être, mais pour moi, le 1 c'est le sapin.
Et à chaque fois que je recommence un groupe de 3 donc que je suis un personnage
Je rajoute vraiment en fond de décor de la scénette mon image de ma table de rappel comme ça tous les 3
Ce qui fait que si on me demande quelle carte est en position 26 par exemple
Je fais 26 divisé par 3 dans ma tête donc ça fait 8
8,6 ça veut dire que c'est l'objet de mon groupe de 8
Je vais aller dans ma tête au groupe numéro 8 donc souvent dans un parc à huîtres ou dans la mer
parce que pour moi en 8 j'ai huître dans ma table de rappel
Je vais avoir le personnage/action/objet et je sais que c'est l'objet en fait le numéro 26 à cet endroit là
Est ce que c'est clair pour un samedi matin ?
Vous savez que je fais cette vidéo très tôt d'ailleurs il est 8h52
Je ne sais pas si à 8h52 je suis très clair
En fait le concept du système PAO c'est simple je crois à expliquer et à comprendre
Après la difficulté c'est de travailler ça pour chaque carte
J'ai un ami Benoit Rosemont qui est spécialiste de la mémoire qui lui à rajouter aussi les émotions, il a rajouter d'autres choses
Je ne peux pas trop vous en parler car ça lui appartient
Mais on peut aller encore plus loin dans le concept en fait pour retenir les cartes par groupe de 5, de 6 voir même plus
Déjà quand on les retient par groupe de 5, ça veut dire qu'on n'a plus que 10 éléments à retenir pour un jeu de 52 cartes
Donc on peut commencer à envisager le double jeu de 52 cartes, c'est à dire les 104 cartes
J'aurais du appeler cette chaîne "Amusons nous avec notre cerveau"
Au niveau de la méthodologie je vous conseille tout d'abord de prendre le temps sur une feuille d'écrire les 52 cartes dans un tableau en fait
Et de mettre en face le nom de chaque personnage, de chaque action, de chaque objet qui correspond à chaque carte
Trouvez vous des astuces également, des astuces mémo techniques pour pouvoir toujours y revenir
Par exemple pour moi, l'objet de tous les as ce sont des monuments historiques
Les personnes de tous les as ce sont des amis à moi qui sont magiciens
Les actions de toutes mes cartes commencent par la 1ère lettre que mon image dans ma table de rappel
Par exemple dans ma table de rappel, 7 c'est tête et vous avez vu que pour le 7 de carreaux c'était tirer
Et pour le 7 de cœur c'est trouer, pour le 7 de trèfle c'est tordre
Voilà comme ça je me trouve une logique
J'ai pleins de logiques comme ça qui sont croisées en fonction de la famille, en fonction du chiffre
Je m'en sers moins aujourd'hui mais ça m'a beaucoup aidé à retenir ça au départ
Puis ça m'aide également quand je me ressers du système PAO quand ça fait longtemps que je ne l'ai pas fait
Je me fais confiance, je n'ai pas peur d'avoir un bug à un moment donné en passant les cartes
Et après, quand vous vous entraînerez, vous les passerez comme ça, lentement, une à une, devant vous en créant vos scénettes par 3
En prenant le temps comme ça
Au départ vous irez très lentement c'est normal il faut aller lentement pour commencer et de plus en plus rapidement
Et après ça deviendra facile, voilà c'était les bases du système PAO
Comme je vous l'ai dit c'était pas le masterclass le plus long à vous expliquer
Par contre c'est sûrement un des plus long à mettre en place voir même de tous ce que je vous ai fait c'est le plus long à mettre en place j'en suis persuadé
N'hésitez pas en fait à séquencer en fait votre masse de travail si vous voulez apprendre à faire ça
si vous voulez apprendre à retenir un jeu de cartes
c'est à dire que amusez vous à faire déjà ça sur les 13 cartes à pique
Donc vous trouvez personnage/action/objet pour les 13 cartes de pique
Et vous mélangez en fait les 13 cartes à pique et vous essayez de les retenir dans l'ordre
Même si ça peut vous paraître simple comme ça, faites le par famille en fait, par groupe de 13
Ca évitera d'essayer de tout faire d'un coup et d'aller à l'échec
Déjà vous allez voir qu'avec 13 cartes on commence à s'amuser
Une fois que vous maîtrisez bien tous les piques, vous passez aux carreaux, après vous faites les trèfles après vous faites les coeurs
et après vous faites tout
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, vraiment
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas vous pouvez vous abonner pour ne pas rater les prochaines vidéos et ça me fait extrêmement plaisir
Vous pouvez aussi commenter si vous avez des questions à me poser
Vous pouvez venir voir les "Hallucinations collectives et autres illusions d'optiques" le 28 mars la prochaine
Et puis moi je suis en spectacle avec "Fabien Olicard vous mentalise"
Les prochaines dates sont à Mulhouse début avril à l'Entrepôt théâtre
et si vous venez on se fait une petite vidéo à la fin en plus
Si tout va bien on devrait passer la barre des 2000 abonnés ce week end
Je voulais vous dire un gros merci par rapport à ça, un très très gros merci
J'avais un objectif à 2500 abonnés pour faire un live avec vous, un espèce de live apéro
Et au départ c'était de l'ordre du fantasme et puis je vois qu'on y arrive en fait, on va y arriver je pense
Pour y arriver encore plus vite vous pouvez partager la vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux, en parler aux gens que ça peut intéresser
Il y a beaucoup d'astuce, il y a les mentalisations des copains,
Il y a les explications du dimanche, ça je sais que vous aimez bien mais que vous aimez bien aussi les garder pour vous
Et d'ailleurs la prochaine explication du dimanche bah ça sera demain alors rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain mental vlog
Tchao